well Senate Democrats say new
revelations about President Trump
withholding military aid from Ukraine
are a turning point in his impeachment
the president tweeted this morning that
the Democrats want to avoid a trial to
protect former Vice President Joe Biden
Ben Tracy is in West Palm Beach Florida
traveling with the president Ben do the
Democrats actually have any leverage
here
well Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer seems to think so he's seizing
on new reporting that President Trump
repeatedly overruled his own national
security team and withholding that aide
from Ukraine these new revelations are a
game changer Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer on Monday said a new
report emphasizes the need for the
Senate trial to have witnesses witnesses
like acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
and former national security adviser
John Bolton according to a New York
Times report president Trump's top
national security advisors including
Bolton tried to convince the president
to release the aide but he overruled
them atop Mulvaney aide is quoted as
saying expect Congress to become
unhinged if the military aid is held up
the new reporting shows that there were
serious concerns raised by Trump
administration officials about the
propriety and legality of what the
president was doing but Republicans
downplayed this as a disagreement with
him the White House I would expect those
guys to share their opinions with the
president I'd also expect them to walk
out and you know either execute the
president's wishes or you know just
maybe even leave if they disagreed with
the president Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo is actually traveling to Ukraine
this week he'll meet with President
zalenski on Friday and that is the same
day the Senate returns to try to hammer
out the details of this impeachment
trial Adriana
Ben thank you
you